so you're wrapping up post-production
untitled my cot project can you tell us
sounds so happy yeah I mean we're
editing we have a 85 minute cut and I
think it's I think it's pretty close we
may be open by next month and then you
said you did some test screenings a
couple more you you receive notes from
people yeah um
how are you with sort of constructive
criticism how is that for you and then
also how does a filmmaker know what to
listen to and then what to go with their
own sort of vision yeah and that's the
tough thing another great piece of
wisdom for my mentor at school always
said no the toughest part about being an
artist is knowing when and when not to
listen to criticism because it never
ends you know like keep taking criticism
for everybody should change this you
know I think you know I mean stuff I
mean there's like you're gonna have
enough passion and remember why you're
making a movie I think and when you go
back to that those are the things that
you keep and then you know the things
that maybe you're not so married to I
don't know I mean 18 out of 20 people
are telling you that like this scene
isn't working because an idiot just a
moment to keep it because like
you know it's the movie however you know
you always think to that point where
it's like some people like certain parts
your films other people phone and I
think that's when you kind of know it's
it is working but it's like somewhere in
between of the feedback that you're
getting but again I think you know
sudden episode the room saying like you
know the opening shot isn't working for
Haley
and when you know that you're done like
looking back on analog days in Little
Rock
I'm sure - there's less pressure you
know just like okay this is cool this is
done but no how are you know you do you
get to the point where you overanalyze
things sort of like analysis paralysis
where you just like or are you more
free-flowing with it how do you know
when you're finished yeah I mean you
know it's my third movie sit on a lot of
experience ain't like you know it's like
different with each project yeah I don't
know I mean that's the nerve-wracking
part is saying like you know I mean
there's that Brian singer talks about
that you can work on a movie forever
literally you just keep changing some
part of it that simmer you have to let
it go you have to say like this is it
where when that is aware that is like I
don't know that's that's kind of the
problem having now it's gonna figure out
what I'm gonna say like the movies done
and then switching gears a little bit
what do you say to filmmakers who think
that they have to have the afterglow as
part of their distribution plan um I
don't know I mean I think it's kind of
antiquated in a way they've a lot people
don't even go to movies anymore and like
there aren't really the teachers showing
stuff and you know it's hard to
get people to go see a movie even a
really good movie like being a
teacher and show you
students like really well done
independent films
they zone out so I I don't think
it's a deal-breaker being a bit
theatrical you know make or break your
movie so sure what now all these other
kind of avenues to like get your filled
out there like that didn't exist even
five years ago and then what things did
you do with little rocket analog days
that you'll never do again then you've
learned the hard way that you go you
know what I'm not gonna do that with
this new project that's good um well
like I said like sending it out before
the film's ready I did it the whole time
I was like I just think it's a mistake
you know having the foam of the best
possible shape with sound and image and
all those things about sending your
screen with a list of like keep this in
mind when you're watching it you know
the fourth scene is gonna be a shot
where I think that's stuff you know it's
the biggest thing I've learned from it
is you know just how collaborative
making film sins and you know it's not
something to resist something to embrace
you know because I think you're having
people that are interpreting things and
bringing their own creativity to it and
I think with lorac I just learned that
it made the feel a lot better and
bracing that kind of stuff opposed I
think with an Alaia days I was much more
like IML director and like as my visions
have you done like this so guess what
what I wouldn't do again is like
P not be open to the things having on
the fly
being open to the creative process
understanding it I guess
and then radio interview you touched on
briefly you know festivals aren't really
a big deal if you hadn't had so many of
the festival fees waived how many do you
think you would have entered and spent
your money because it does add up
yeah well I don't think that they're not
I mean I think like you know it's witty
your film out there and again like you
know who doesn't want to be in a
festival and you know going to festivals
a lot of times well the only good part
of being a filmmaker you know they get
to go to another country for free and
sugar films and like it's amazing but
you know I just I guess what I was
trying to say more is like you know
getting your film into Sundance or South
by Southwest or one of the big hustles
I'm gonna change your life you know
you're still gonna finish your film you
have to make another one you
know and that's you know not that you
shouldn't send it in if you get in
probably be great but you know it's not
the golden ticket to to you know a life
with supermodels that in a mansion or
anything but I think it's really
important to send it out to as many
places as possible I mean I think it's
something you should write into the
budget but when you're making your movie
because like you know to do all this
work and put all this effort into a film
and then not send it to some festivities
you want to spend 30 more dollars like
it does that up but like it's part
getting fun out there you know and you
know I've done some like really with
analyte days some of the people that
I've ended up helping me out down the
road or weird people I met at some like
cynic West in San Jose and I still talk
to this producer there who got me a job
you're doing the stock energy for INXS
which just met him this is like
rinky-dink festival I don't really take
that you know it's not a huge festival
like so I mean you know and a lot of
really great things happen with Little
Rock or just people I've met so yeah bar
that festival party who ended up
you know excited when I film somewhere I
think it's really important you know
just send out as many places as possible
and especially European ones because
most of them are free